Associated with every linear program
is a so-called dual program,
which is also a linear program.
This definition is most elegant when
stated in terms of the symmetric form.
Indeed, now you see why this
form gets the name symmetric.
As we saw in the exercise, the dual
program can be thought of as the problem
of minimizing an upper bound
on the primal program.
Observe that for all feasible y,
we have that b transposed y
is at least y transposed Ax.
Here we've just used this
constraint here from the primal and
the non-negativity of y from the dual.
And this in turn, is at most cTx,
by the constraints of the dual here,
and the non-negativity
of x in the primal.
In fact,
we just proved the weak duality lemma,
which states that if x is feasible for
the primal, and y is feasible for
the dual, then cTx is at most, bTy.
That is to say, that the value of the
primal is at most the value of the dual.
And this makes sense because we built
the dual as essentially an upper bound
on the primal.
Another thing to note here,
is that if your primal problem
isn't in this exact form,
you can always convert it and
then look at the corresponding dual and
simplify it.
Often, however, it's easier just to
remember that the dual is the problem of
bounding the primal as
tightly as possible.
For instance, if we change the primal
inequality to an equality, then we can
proceed by the same argument, only this
first inequality becomes an equality.
And I don't have to rely on
the y being non-negative.
Everything else stays the same.